all right this is from wpde.com a
teenager in New Hampshire has become the
first transgender contestant to win a
local Miss America organization beauty
pageant
Brian Gwynn
didn't even change his name he's still
Brian 19 won Sunday night's pageant to
become Miss greater Dairy 2023 which
Awards a uh Awards the winner a crown a
title and a scholarship
I think we have the footage of this uh
of this young man winning the beauty
pageant yeah we do uh let's let's watch
that
can we skip to the good part
[Music]
so
as you can see that's uh
you know it's the offensive lineman with
the Detroit Lions that just won the the
Miss America Pageant there it's like
there's a an obese man
was awarded the beauty pageant winner
um
Gwen announced on Instagram in the 100
Year history of Miss America I have
officially become the first transgender
title holder within the Miss America
organization
no words can describe the feeling of
having the opportunity to serve my
community and represent my community for
the very first time at Miss New
Hampshire I am so honored to be crowned
your new Miss greater Dairy 2023 and I
am thrilled to show you all what I have
up my sleeves
really don't want to see
this will be an amazing year using
techniques that have been honed and
perfected by generations of bladesmiths
kamikoto knives are crafted only of high
quality Japanese steel each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish then I'm supposed to
show you one of them uh here are the
knives
right here these are beautiful knives
with more than 100 years of experience
between them kamikodo's expert
bladesmiths shape of raw Japanese steel
into hearty blades polishing and
sharpening them to excruciatingly fine
single bevel Edge this sharp edge is why
camacody knives can cut through Meat and
Fish like butter and it's why they're
used by Michelin star chefs all around
the world each knife is individually
inspected and comes with a lifetime
guarantee plus kamikoto knives come in a
beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box which
you can see right here for safe storage
this stunning presentation makes
kamikoto a great gift during this
holiday season kimikoto is now running a
Black Friday sale and offering my
viewers an additional 50 off any
purchase with discount code Welsh go to
kamikoto.com Walsh to get your knives
set and also help support our Channel
That's kamikoto.com
there's a few things going on here one
of them it goes back to something I
talked about with Joe Rogan uh on Monday
and he brought up
that you know this this gender ideology
stuff it it affords people there's of
course a lot of narcissism involved in
it and that's that's certainly the case
here but also force people the
opportunity to to like uh
earn something
or have an achievement
despite having achieved nothing like you
don't have to work for you don't have to
do anything you don't have to accomplish
anything
and suddenly you you have achieved
something
that's a lot of this so this guy has uh
the first in a hundred years I'm a
Trailblazer he didn't do anything he put
on a dress he just showed up at this uh
at this beauty pageant
and he won as soon as he walked in the
door because for the people deciding who
the winner is he was he presented to
them an opportunity to Virtue signal and
they took it you know this is the
Northeast this is New Hampshire they're
gonna they're gonna take that
opportunity as soon as he presents it to
them so he did nothing
and yet he gets to claim this title for
himself I'm the first in 100 years to
what an achievement
so there's a lot of that but also also
consider that
you know I know what the body positivity
stuff that uh you know we're we're
entering a world where very often
you know you know an obese woman maybe
could win a title like that but I think
what's what's more likely I mean look at
all the other you see him and then
compare him to all of the actual women
on stage
and you notice a difference
well there are there's a number of
differences
but one of them is that all the other he
is morbidly obese and none of the other
women are none of the actual women are I
should say
the point is that
if he looked exactly like that
but was actually a woman
Not only would he not have one Miss
America he would not have been allowed
on the stage
and that's it's kind of interesting too
because I've I've pointed out before
that when it comes to this body
positivity stuff
the one thing missing are men usually
because usually when you see you know
when some uh brand puts out an
advertisement celebrating body
positivity with a with an obese model
you know it's it's almost always women
you very rarely see a guy with a big fat
beer gut you know appearing in a in a
dove ad or something like that
um as a champion of body positivity the
plus size models very rarely men
so body positivity celebrating obesity
almost always applies to women not men
except in this case
if the man is pretending to be a woman
that's how twisted Things Are and I'll
do it for this portion of the show is
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you on
Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign